e
eu
não posso falar aqui e pronto
vamos não sabe
pessoal podem mudar aqui sejam muito bem
vindos a mais um vídeo eu hoje trago-vos
aqui uma caixa com 12 brinquedos dos
anos 90 de brinquedos nostálgicos quem
tem a minha idade de 25 anos para cima
sabe que estes brinquedos aqui nunca
mais vão ser feitos neste planeta porque
eram bem divertidos muitos destes
brinquedos aqui nós somos originais Ok
era só conseguir encontrar mesmo forma
fake Mas enfim sempre propósito embora
vai entender os dos brinquedos
nostálgicos dos anos 90 este aqui é um
clássico e bem pulei
tal como eu me sinto é isso não é
super super esta lei
pode estar aqui mas por que que eu fosse
buscar uma coisa séria por estes aqui
pessoal quem foram os que eu brinquei na
minha infância eu nunca tive a
oportunidade de ter um bebê lei da série
Ok porque eram bastante carros na altura
então eu sempre brinquei com estes aqui
fake e eu quis o máximo trazer a
nostalgia portanto fui buscar
precisamente os brinquedos que brinquei
na minha infância a maioria eram feitos
né porque não tinha dinheiro em palavras
mas mesmo assim a minha mãe ainda se
esforçava muito para me conseguir dar
este Então vale a pena Esse é o lançador
do Beyblade ó acho que mais ou menos
isto acho que ao contrário não é assim
aqui temos a cordinha
olha está a funcionar por enquanto
e aqui pessoal nosso Beyblade de Metal
atenção de metal muitos foi o imposto e
coloque por causa que tipo a sorte de
ter sair um tal aí
[Música]
ia ser mais bravos frase clássica ler e
olha isso foi
este este leva um bocado Mas vamos
tentar outra vez calma eu estou tirando
a minha paz o presente também na minha
altura existiam escolheram com cordinha
eram os que tinham apenas um botão e
assistiram buscarem a vão sempre meu
esse é muito potente o Eric veio Olha
isso por feito a está a está
Olha isso acrobacias aqui quando a gente
presta Ok próximo brinquedo
de mão Esta é uma classe que eu acho que
até hoje as crianças ainda bem com quem
estão classe ó calma mas esta não é uma
qualquer esta dos Avengers Olha aí
e eu era mentindo Capitão América é
vamos dos Avengers e aqui em cima ainda
tem um joguinho para que chegou aqui
desculpa
Quem brinca com isso é psicopata
uma coisa de fazer
não é
[Música]
não
sabe fazer
eu ainda pegava assim Calma calma eu
ainda pegava e brincava com ela tchau
ó ó ainda não estava assim duas ou ó
dá uma ligada obrigado
o café mas olha aí
outro brinquedo bem simples mas com
muita gente nos anos 90 brincou eu tenho
aqui duas inclusive boa saltitona em
toda a casa de qualquer criança nos anos
90 tinha bola saltitona era impossível
tinha também em todos os
estabelecimentos tipo em todas as
papelarias em todo o restaurante ele é
aquelas maquininhas por 50 cm de altura
aqui em Portugal por 50 escudos escudos
tela também sabia sempre essas
maquininhas onde vocês colocaram a moeda
e saíram várias bolas Ela está de passar
um dia patrão se nisto Mas é uma
marcante quem tem parte uma coisa dessas
bolas Eu nunca perdi eu nunca parte nada
com essa LOL que eles fracos da parede
que os pais adoram nunca tive de espaço
em casa e isso é coisa de família e que
eu nunca tive prato prato para até na
mesa para comer pau na parede quanto na
parede é família rica já é é
só Comente o que é que vocês acham
Alguma de vocês tentar na parede tiverem
já sei que vocês vivem bem próximo Quem
nunca brincou com um Diablo Este é o
clássico dos clássicos e eu tinha amigos
na escola também que eram muito pros foi
esse brinquedo é assim eu confesso que
na altura eu tinha uma qualidade melhor
mas também este aqui acho que é o diabo
falso né porque este sozinhos são bem
podres e olha realmente o diabo era
maior e mais pesado mas eu só consegui
encontrar esta versão atualmente à venda
nos que eu vi originais eram bastante
caros então só vem buscar aqui para
vocês que eu consegui arranjar este o
pessoal mais novo deve estar a pensar
que seca como é que eles brincavam com
os bem peludinho também tem sim 2024
brincava com Leite faz uma corda
parece bem primitivo até Calma vou
testar aqui tem que estar um balanço
aqui
e agora vai
o o então foi meu ainda me lembro acho
que é só isto era assim agora tira solar
e E aí
ah
está é isso ele está Eu agora aqui na
hora
de conseguir conseguir
Ai meu Deus eu pensei que é
[Música]
o
OK esquece eu não sei Padre próximo
brinquedo a consola portátil mais antiga
de todas
aqui está este é um seguinte bolinhas
com água onde nós temos que achar estas
argolas dentro dos Palitos tiverem
alguém com a minha idade a ver este
vídeo comentei isso nunca brincou com
esta coisa meu gostei e muitos ano eu
quero as argolas aqui todas é bem
difícil eu consigo enviar umas quatro ou
cinco mas quando vocês querem enfiar as
restantes as outras estranho então
Oi
tia Rita tanto Está divertido ao mesmo
tempo irrita porque eu não consigo meter
as argolas Ele próximo a outra consola
melhor que esta que eu tenho aqui dentro
Okay mas vamos ver mais para o fim do
vídeo aqui é mas vamos continuar outro
brinquedo clássico que toda a gente teve
nos anos 90
pega monstro quem é que o meu juro
comentei isso só se eles tiverem idade
isso brincaram com isto comentem eu
quero ver quantas pessoas daí é que
brincaram com estas coisas que eu tenho
certeza que a maioria do meu público nem
sequer tocou nem viu a frente um pega
mostro destes qual era o pai que não sei
que estava com isto porque porque isso
tinha um se não quer manchar a parede
exato mas sábado tudo e o pior era o pé
de monstro verde o verde era o pior de
sempre Vejam a viscosidade qual slime
qual que é claro slime 2017 para cima
antes eram pega um monstro vem aqui a
senhora gordinha para colocarmos o dedo
aqui daqui mas como é que tu brincas com
a mostrar banho eu como eu quero mais
tarde aparelho vou estar aqui só que o
meu armário que dá para limpar melhor
basicamente do jogar este é
o texto é
é
só assim não pois não é uma coisa já
percebi isso agarra bem na parede Já
entendi já tá velha poder sabe
e
depois avistou assim toma tá
o próximo brinquedo o clássico e o
quem não brinco com ioiô A concurso e
tudo aqui no meio
Eu sei fazer isso mas não com este oeste
daqui é bem podre né é mais uma vez este
aqui não é o martírio ou oficial Ok é um
hip hop é um fake Mas enfim dá para o
gasto que vai me ajudar aqui na
demonstração
vai estalos
olha olha ele ficou lá
é bem podre de cima
japui olha a luz
Agora sim é muito abusado a
e toma falei só isso
E aí
é isso não tava favor hoje já comenta aí
pessoal desde já a vossa brinquedo
preferido Ok ou então espera até o fim
do vídeo vejam os restantes outro
clássico
barulho de
Quem nunca brincou com Marquinhos até no
espelho game Tem lá um jogo com verniz
eu acho que não vou abrir isto que eu eu
por acaso acho que satisfatório assim um
saquinho cheio de vergonha mas é isso
aqui até são bonitinhos porque da minha
altura eu brincava com um verniz
transparente de vidro mesmo ainda tinha
a todos que eram aqueles os abafadores
aqueles grandes dores eram tão jovens
nas escolas os grandalhões esse aí mas
estavam jogo tudo próximo brinquedo mais
Um clássico que eu também brinquei muito
soldadinhos verdes
soldadinhos que indígenas também não eu
brinquei muito com esse brinquedos muito
havia sempre os soldadinhos com armas e
tinham também os indígenas com com setas
com flechas com escudos geralmente
quando acaba as lojas tipo on TV e os
carros havia são os mais em conta e isso
mas mais em conta obviamente elas que
comprarem o que a minha mãe comprava
para mim que eu sempre vários pacotes de
salgadinhos e indígenas também Ele amava
assim que uma guerra entre eles e claro
os indígenas ganharam sempre por corre
para quem é que é mais bravo com certa
com essa com veneno de cobra na ponta e
a sua mãe aí bem justo conquistou aí com
a capa com a M16 não viu Eles são muito
mais baratos além espada e escudo meu E
este aqui lembro muito a história aquela
animação tipo deles a correr pela casa e
tudo fora próximo eles não é bem um
brinquedo Ok mas vende dos anos 80 anos
90 por acaso os que eu tenho aqui é bem
antigo mesmo ó eu tenho aqui uma opção
do Mickey
1988 Olha aí é quase dez anos 90 até
tenho aqui uma do Pato Donald Eu não sei
ao certo mas eles trocam sempre até
tenho aqui um anúncio do Ioiô Olha só
não se tem aqui coca-cola clássica e o
anúncio do Ioiô tem um campeonato aqui
tudo meu Deus é participe torna um
campeão e ganhos e os pontos baixos
prêmios basicamente o prêmio era a
coca-cola
incrível 1981 é mais anticast ainda
outro Pato Donald outra versão do Mickey
tenho aqui também um homem aranha este
Homem Aranha deve ser muito antigo calma
Isto é de que ano 15/16 de 1987 muito
antigo e tenho um adulto uma medida o
Hulk com um patrocínio aqui da nesse tom
festa do Brasil né não estão nunca
desista em Portugal neste Tom Katniss
Neto Não mexe com um tem Portugal Mas
neste Tom não
acho que no Brasil não este aqui deve
ter uma versão do Brasil só aqui do
Brasil que acompanha o canal explica
melhor o que é o neste Tom que a Turma
da Mônica e o Cebolinha esta é de
1982 esta revista que está aqui é mais
velha que eu é impressionante estar
apegado em coisas mais velhas que eu
quantas pessoas é que já não leram a o
colégio que são os mesmos páginas tão
bem escura já desgastadas com o tempo
para isso
tem que ir várias histórias o que eu
mais gostava era do Pato Donald Com
certeza aqui temos patinho só tem vários
anúncios aqui inclusive anúncios bem que
estamos aqui o dele Ô
aqui ó aqui tem ganache clique em um
curso de Nesquik
é só tem que ir passatempo para ganhar
uma t-shirt
da Disney né
Ok vamos ver aqui outras tem aqui
chupitos que eu não conheço o que acho
pedidos eu não sei o que é estúpidos Mas
pode também são as Barrinhas de Sumo que
eram os antigos faz olha para que eu
falar neles para que ele não chegou fa o
pai tipo um gelado de gelo concorrente e
eu comi bastante mas não eram os
verdadeiros eu já comi outros que eram
os do pinguim sabe a maioria das pessoas
lhe estas vidas quando a casa de banho
como eu hoje em dia o que é que nós
fazemos que vemos o rótulo do shampoo
próximo estação dos brinquedos pessoal e
eu deixei os dois melhores para o final
da que dos melhores mais do que os que
já mostraste é verdade tenho dois
brinquedos aqui que são os verdadeiros
os verdadeiros que eu tenho certeza que
toda a gente da minha idade brincou com
eles
Olha aí Tamagotchi mais uma vez isso não
é original não é o Tamagotchi é aqui
mesmo porque está eu nunca tive o
Tamagotchi seguir ela que tu sempre
estes assim fake então ele tá quis
mostrar o teu brinquei Eu acho que só
tem que retirar esta planeta daqui para
a vida funcionar
e já ligou
O que é um coelho sim
ok só funciona
e ela tem que páreos tem um sapo tem um
cão pode escolher a vaca um gato ok que
ia para alimentar aqui é para brincar
com ele para tem as horas aí tu duas da
manhã agora supostamente
ela possa alterar aqui ok Olha eu vou
baixar aqui está o nosso Pet pessoal eu
ainda está em ovo eu acho espera olha
abriu-a
e é uma galinha
que
saudades
sempre nunca percebi porque e para quem
sabe disso pela primeira vez Isto é
basicamente o vosso animal de estimação
portátil Ok se vocês têm que o alimentar
brincar de acarinhar sempre todos pedir
e a função eu não deixarem que ele morra
e uma coisa muito boa aqui 10 Tamagotchi
é que vocês podiam partilhar ou brincar
com os vossos animais de estimação com
outros tamagotchis através de
infravermelho que tem aqui eu acho que
era só você sempre estarem eles
interagem algum com gotas que era
incrível Este é o verdadeiro pode ser o
último brinquedo aqui da Caixa
game Este é um verdadeiro Brick game
basicamente isso é uma consola portátil
com
9999 jogos eu não estou a brincar
pessoal é verdade isso temos o nosso
quase 10.000 jogos aqui dentro
obviamente que são jogos bem limitados e
são variações do mesmo jogo imaginemos
nós temos aqui um bastante Popular que é
o E aí dentro do Tetris Temos vários
modos de jogo em que é considerado um
jogo então provavelmente aquilo deve ter
umas mil versões do Tetris deve ter umas
um versões de fórmula 1 que tem jogo
Fórmula 1 aqui dentro deve ter umas
numerações do arkanoid que é que elas
baratas em cima e onde vocês mexem tem
várias versões para os jogos aqui dentro
mas o técnico Tetris é o verdadeiro
pessoal eu vou colocar aqui pilhas e
vamos ver como ele funciona e
E aí
[Música]
o ok tem o jogo aqui dos tanques e
celebração conhecido
calma calma calma calma já foste
mas já foste tem outros aqui então não
E isso
não tem muito tempo tá bom
[Aplausos]
estava difícil porque a velocidade era
assento e o Miguel era o três Ok eu
configurei que o nível estranho
e
o jogo de corridas com carros eu quero
perguntar este fora
o jogo Fórmula 1 há uma possa acelerar
aqui top de linha e isso e literal gente
na dos anos 90 pessoal Olha esse GTA
calma agora troca aqui a parte de trás
por trás é que paga pessoal é
a
mamãe ai eu nem ligo e
G1
tu não dorme não
E aí vai subindo essa dificuldade aqui
vai explodir o
E aí
a
bela e
e pronto falta do vir aqui isso já não
sei lá então acaba quando eu tô sabe
qual é a vantagem desta consola na
altura pessoal bastante divertida de mal
já estavam pilha e segurava imenso tempo
e o principal acaba para competir com
todos os vossos amigos que tivessem
também este joguinho e não era nada caro
está super em conta super barato mas
agora tem mais brinquedos pessoal tem
mais brinquedos que eu não consegui
encontrar importante porque sou mesmo
bastante raros Mas se vocês gostarem
deste vídeo e fizerem ver mais e o monte
outra caixa com certeza vocês vão adorar
os brinquedos que eu vou trazer
simplesmente preciso mais de tempo mas é
isso Pessoal espero que tenham gostado
aqui neste vídeo já estava então se
quiserem ver outra caixa com mais
brinquedos dos anos 90 outro qualquer
outro ano se quiserem tipo dos anos 80
270 eu vou em busca mas só se valer a
pena pessoal e como é que vale a pena Se
vocês deixarem muito like aqui neste
vídeo Compartilhar este ainda não ligou
mais velho ou Se tiverem mais nos quais
em casa pessoal mostrem este vídeo eu
tenho certeza que ele já brincaram com
isso aqui vão se identificar pessoal mas
é isso espero que tenham gostado fiquem
e até a próxima